they're still on us these guys are
taking this person we got more of our
fanclub dead ahead
phase two phase two what's phase two
pounds away
[Applause]
you know what I like about you dumb
you're a genuine outlaw but you're his
family the hell of a job brother we get
back to the base beers on me it's about
to go up against anything they can't
handle you did you ever think you'd
betray your family the way you did today
Dominic Toretto just turned on us well
well - look at that I will beat you like
a Cherokee drum I don't know why he's
doing this
but that wasn't done she's the very
definition of high-tech terrorism now
she's working with your guy I think I
found my team you want to play like that
ouch this is impossible
which is why they gonna need a little
help you guys are gonna work together I
just from love have been waiting for
this we got a tank let's roll here they
come
I don't know if the old Dom is in there
I don't give a damn I'm taking you down
so right off let's play
where is she met me I don't know
[Music]
we're gonna need a bigger truck
um you're gonna turn your back on family
[Music]